my name is orianne
and i work at appei which is a
consultancy and projects company that
connect research and with production and
today i'm here to talk about my work in
the realm of audio
my background is in compute a
computational branch of cognition which
means i love machine learning perception
psychophysics
and anything that has anything to do
with computational human related models
i don't work alone
and i'm very lucky to be working in my
company with the talented schenberg that
also happens to be here in the audience
today
and most of what i'll be discussing here
is a part of our collaborative work
so
[Music]
humans
in the loop
who are those humans
and how to avoid them it was only after
i submitted and was accepted to this
conference that i realized that the
entire talk is going to be about
avoiding humans
and so
i think that
for most of us here working in data
science when we think about humans in
the loop what we think about essentially
is
the
our constant need of getting
labeled manually labeled data
that represents our human perception
but honestly if
when i look deeper and think about
humans in the loop i also see that we
are the humans in the loop
because
throughout our day
when i work with audio i use my
perception my hearing all the time i
cannot avoid
listening to whatever is coming in and
out and constantly checking
the quality of the work i'm doing try
and imagine a deaf person working in the
realm of audio these days as an engineer
they wouldn't be able still to do it
because our perception is key our own
engineering perception is key to our
day-to-day
tasks
and so
um
these two
key or these two notes of where humans
exist in the loop are the ones i want i
want to address today
and the way i'm going to do it is by
telling you two stories
the first one
will be about working with weekly label
data in a breath detector we built
and the second one will be about
perceptual
quality algorithms we use to
minimize the need to listen tediously to
many many examples
while trying to improve an algorithm we
were building
so let's start with the first one
um
it is worth mentioning that there are
other ways to reduce the need for
manually tagged data which are for
example unsupervised models and transfer
learning
and they are great but i don't have
enough time to talk about everything so
these are the two examples i'll be
discussing today
so
weekly label data for breath detection
let's talk about that challenge
we needed to create a breath detector in
speech as part of a bigger project
the challenge was data as it most time
is in audio or rather that there wasn't
any
we knew we could in this case hire a
manual tagger to create a breadth data
set but also that this would take time
and we wanted to start working on the
algorithm right away
so after some thought and
brainstorming we came up with the
following question
what happens when you take library
speech
which is
i'll tell you about it in a second and
sub subtract all the words from it libre
speech for those of you that don't know
is an open data set of roughly 1 000
hours of book recordings with accurately
aligned transcriptions
we figured after listening to some
samples that removing the speech from
libri would leave us with breaths and
silences or so we were hoping and we
also figured that breaths are more
audible than silences
so just to give you the feel of things i
will
play
a short sample of what library speech
sounds like
wait
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us
this is not the right example
good perception everybody
wait
this is the next one right
um
this is the right one she popped into
her new house and sat there comfortably
peering out through the window slits
with her sharp little eyes
she popped in so in this snippet we can
see and also i'll try and pinpoint the
fact that there are two breaths
which are marked in orange just before
she start to speak and in between in
between sorry
wait
she popped uh it's really inaudible here
but you'll have to believe me that
they're comfortably appearing okay
that little
that is what we were looking for
and we noticed it exists in
you know the entire data set it's just
not tagged
so
after removing
all okay so delivery speech
has a very accurate alignment of all the
areas where there are attacks it's a
very common data set for audio and after
removing all the speech from libre
speech what we essentially ended up
having
were
many many tiny snippets that we can see
here concatenated i will
explain in a sec
that had either a breath or silence in
them this is a visual visualization of
the non-speech parts we extracted what
we're seeing is a few hundred
concatenated snippets like one row after
the other
and between each pair of white lines
is a separate snippet that can be one of
three things a breath a silence or noise
we took
we were very happy to see and i can
hardly imagine we can see it here but
you'll have to trust me on this that it
is
pretty visible
to distinguish with our human eyes
between a breath and a silence
so
after staring at the snippets image and
listening to examples from it we had a
pretty good sense just by looking at the
snippets which have a breath and which
doesn't
this was really a good sign for us it
led us to take 10
we took 10 minutes and quickly manually
tagged 300 examples
but we wanted more so we took those 300
examples and essentially sliced them up
to tiny fragments of 20 milliseconds
each and this gave us 4
and 800 samples on which we trained an
sdm a very simple model
and what we were expecting to see and is
a bit hard but let's try and see it here
is that there will be two clusters
a shared messy cluster which will have
parts of snippets that are breath and
parts that are silenced because in each
breath there's the beginning and the
ending which is silence
and there will be a cluster of only
breaths and this is what we see in blue
and red here
and the dashed line
is the decision boundary of the stm
so
by looking at this we were already quite
positive but still we didn't have a lot
of examples and this model was making a
lot of mistakes
our next step
was
to run the svm model on not snip
on the parts that are not speech
snippets from livery speech extracted
from 100 hours of library speech
and create a data set of
a huge number of samples 92
000 samples comprised of snippets that
were either labeled as breath
or silence or neither which is
essentially the speech parts of libre
speech
we used the data set to train a small
cnn and the results did a better job
than the svm in detecting breaths
so the next iteration of this project
was to retrain
everything again
and
to retag the dataset we had using the
cnn
and here
we started this iterative process of
recreating the data set again which
improved as i said our auc scores from
91 to 94.8
to finish the project
we were pretty happy already with 94.8
but
we added in the end the tag data that we
sent off making
and uh we also added a we found a
karaoke data set named mir1k that has
only uh the vocals part in it so we
figured
the the breaths there can help us and
eventually uh we brought our asc scores
to be 97.4 which was more than
sufficient for us
so
that's how we handled
the weekly label data and created our
very much desired breath detection
[Music]
any questions about this section before
we move yes okay
i kinda was late but why why do you need
bread detection you might have said it
no no i didn't say it right uh i i can't
really elaborate on that the reason i
needed a breast detector for it was uh
yeah
thank you for asking though it's a good
question right
it's a similar question the previous one
but i would ask you to tell me why i'm
just wondering if you just want to find
out if someone is in the room breathing
or the other microphone breathing is
there a different kind of breathing to
the breathing between words or between i
i was i would say that it is oh i never
imagined that this would spark so much
curiosity not to say
the exact reason i built this for but i
mean it wasn't as exciting as you guys
are going with this i love the work the
places you're going i mean we're open
for any project that is as cool as
you're imagining right now but
imagine some sort of an editing
algorithm that is trying to improve
speech quality somehow and
looking at the breaths and understanding
that not being able to notice them
causes some sort of trouble and
understanding that if we could only add
those breaths to the project then we
will have a far better outcome
okay
so
so that was our first part let's go to
the second one
which is um perception algorithms and
honestly this is such a huge topic that
i can't believe i'm even trying to talk
about it shortly but um let's let's be
brave together and give it a go
so in this case um
we were working on improving an
algorithm throughout an iterative
process where we had you know a
repository different branches to the
repository each branch was a new version
of the algorithm and we wanted to test
out whether the new version is better or
worse
than
our
master repository branch
and so
we had to come up with a way to work in
a team and say
uh should we adopt a new version or
shouldn't we
and and to do so we chose 50 tracks that
were our benchmark they represented the
field of all the different
um missions that are our model
needed to to complete
and with each version
our uh
all the team basically had to sit and
listen to to those 50 tracks and
understand whether there's an
improvement or not because it's it was a
very delicate perceptual task and
the different versions sometimes or even
oftentimes were improving one part of
the needed task but also degrading other
areas of
what we were working on
and so after doing this for a while we
realized that it would help us immensely
to have some sort of scale
with the different tracks on them so
that we could know where was the biggest
change between the the version we're
testing and the old version i mean just
to to be able to shift our attention to
the areas where the most different
differences are taking place
and so
i thought this would be an easy task i i
thought this is a day of work just to
say if the new version is similar or
different than the old version not to
say if it's better or worse i thought
better or worse that's hard to to
achieve but just saying if it's the same
or different
i thought it's easy little did i know
that not only is it not easy these are
multiple different tasks
because each different um
each different
challenge here is tested separately and
they don't generalize well so to measure
the quality or intelligibility of a
track is one mission and artificially
generated data or edited data is another
doing speech is one thing music is
another live is one thing offline is
another
with reference is one without is another
you get the point people got really
angry at me on the internet for asking
this very general question so i
figured i better have this slide to make
the point of saying this is not just one
question it's like a hundred of them
but the gist of why is it so needed and
it's so hard to generalize is that
the audio our audio perception
of sound
is really not linear and it's not
linearly correlated with the audio
signal itself
human hearing highlights and weakens the
auditory signal in a non-linear way when
a person hears something that that
something arrives at their ear and later
brain as a mechanical sound wave
traveling and vibrating through the air
i like to think of it as
three-dimensional ripples all around us
all the time
there are maps that correlate between
the human perception and the physical
audio signal here we can observe the
physical metric on the y-axis which
represents pressure level
loudness is the experience correlated
with decibels which is the y-axis
on the x-axis we see the frequency which
is pressure over time pitch is the
experience correlated with
frequency
and on wave on the the wavy lines on the
graph itself are the human experience
but that's not a perfect mapping and
definitely not the whole story of our
auditory perception it's only the
beginning
our brain can add and subtract sounds
and most literally play with our head in
various ways
i also think it's interesting to note in
this graph which is very famous it's
like it's been researched for 100 years
that
the areas at which we have the best
resolution the areas at which we we have
the best perception for are those of the
human speech are the areas of the
frequencies of the human speech we are
specialized in hearing those frequencies
specifically or maybe it's the other way
around
we are
created such that our frequency of
speech is the one that is perceived best
by our ears and brain
and so
the way that this was
researched and still is researched
manually is
by mean opinion scores
tests or moss
and this is the manual human quality
tests that are made today and for the
past tens of years
here's how it works
a person is listening to two tracks and
is asked to rank how similar or
different they are on a one to five
scale or they listen to one track and
rank what's its quality between one and
five
the thing is that's a pretty hard task
if you think about it people do it over
and over again
and there are difficult uh and it's
difficult to do this
and and uh erica cooper noted that these
tests are consistent within their selves
but she showed really rather beautifully
that they are not consistent consistent
between each other that is to say for
example if a listener rated the quality
of a track as four
in one test and a different track also
received four in a different task that
does not mean that these two tracks will
get four a four rating in a third
measurement or that their quality would
be perceived as the same
it's important to note that even though
most tests have many difficulties they
are the product of years of work and
they are still the best that we have in
terms of assessing quality or similarity
when we come to measure the human
perception
and all of the new and shiny neural
networks that i'm going to show are
trying to are trying hard to reach
the the outcome of those tests they're
the benchmark for the human perception
so to get the gist of uh comparing two
tracks together let's walk through like
the very simple intuition of it if i'm
trying to compare two tracks here it's
we want v1 and it should have been v2
but essentially it's the same track
and i'll subs subtract them from one
another or i'll correlate them
it it makes a lot of sense to think that
subtracting them would lead to zero
which will be a good way of telling if
they're the same or different right
the thing is with uh the audio signal is
that if i change those tracks and
add a bit of silence in the beginning
and in the ending of each of those
tracks or even in one of them doesn't
matter and subtract subtract them
then what i'll get will be a very
i will
let's have a listen to what we'll get
but it it will sound pretty okay
okay let's go here
um
so
this is just the v1 without any changes
to it we were so deep in the grass that
we could see nothing but the blue sky
over us and the gold tree in front of us
and
this is
the
um
padded
silences the the subtraction the orange
track here sounds like this
we were so deep in the grass that we
could see nothing but the blue sky over
us and the gold tree in front of us
so clearly when we want to measure
whether two tracks are the same or
different
we need to to do some sort of alignment
to them but that's not the only thing we
need to do in order to say if they're
the same or not
the other thing that we would need to do
is to look at them
[Music]
at each of the tracks as a
relative to itself
because we can see that even we if we
add noise we're really good our
perception is really good at
understanding the signal if we add
stochastic noise to it to a very big
degree
[Music]
so we're
skipping several iterations of this
demonstration showing how our human
perception is coping pretty well with
added stochastic noise and all sorts of
general manipulations and going straight
to looking at a log male spectrogram
which is the most common representation
of audio and learning algorithms
the reason that it's so common is that
this representation captures the human
perception really well
the y axis represents the frequency and
is log scale to match the human ear and
the color scale represents loudness in
decibels also on a logarithmic scale
the idea of scaling the frequencies and
loudness on a log scale is used in
almost all comparison algorithms old and
new
and we can say that the need to align
two tracks and then correlate each
section is at the heart of many of the
comparison algorithms
so a bit about the contemporary
approaches or maybe uh start off with
what was before the contemporary
approaches
[Music]
with the rise of telecommunication and
radio in the beginning of the 20th
century rose a new type of engineering
and there was a need
to really assess how well it is the the
audio quality that is being transmitted
and is being used
it started messy and became similar to
some tools we still use today around the
80s and 90s it was led by
telecommunication companies as i said
that wanted reliable audio
in the radio and phone lines their
approaches were theory-driven and
rule-based they patented their work and
charged a fee they still charge a fee to
use their products to this day
in recent years there are efforts to
change the paradigm into learning
algorithms that are
black box in nature
and rely upon data sets of human ratings
many of the contemporary works are open
sourced yay
okay so the next part is a bit of a
cheat sheet i made when i had to uh
assess the different algorithms so i'll
just share it it's it's i hope we'll all
cope with it together
um i'll just say that there are many com
competitors in the race towards quality
and similarity assessments algorithms
and i'm going to just talk about a few
of them
um
the ones i'm going to talk about they
capture the different families of
approaches that differ by factors
i care about and i believe that if i was
to give a similar talk like this next
year the algorithms will be might be
different because they are changing
rather fast
so in the first and second row
we see the old school algorithms or the
first one is really the
telecommunications one peak pasc and
polka these are the telecommun telecom
comparison algorithms task especially is
often used in academic publications as a
scoring method
in fields such as noise suppression echo
cancellation and speech enhancement the
second row fiscal is an algorithm by
google which is very similar in design
but it's open source and free to use it
uses perceptually motivated feature
extraction time alignment and image
comparison
it's almost exactly as sim if you happen
to know of it
and it generates also a similarity score
in the end
what's nice about this call except for
it being open source is that new
versions of it work
in audio in general and not only in
speech
which is important if you're working
with music or if you're doing things
that are more about noise and
specifically well anything that is in
speech directly
what's not so nice about vscall and it's
really the main difference between the
old generation and
neural network based ones that are in
the three uh
bottom columns is that it's not
differentiable so we can't really use it
if we want to add it to a loss as part
of a loss function when we're trying
training a neural net
um
moving forward
we can see mossnet which is a cnn
trained to predict human mass ratings
from spectrograms the big advantages of
it are that there's no need for a
reference while using it and it is
differentiable as i said a big plus
but it doesn't generalize well this is
true for all of them actually
most tests here
demonstrate their ability and quality on
a certain set of examples and tests but
it's really hard to know whether they're
going to generalize to your own specific
tasks so it is it does require a bit of
manual testing of the different
algorithms to see which one is the right
one for you and which one will do the
best work
[Music]
going forward cdp am is a neural network
that computes similarity score directly
from two-way forms so it require it
requires reference but also it's good if
you're trying to
compare a good or a different version of
something to an older version
the advantages is that it works directly
on the waveform this is quite
unusual and uses no signal processing so
it can better learn human perception as
there are no
preconceptions about how humans perceive
sound it uses self-supervised learning
so it doesn't need a lot of tagged data
and generalizes well
and the last one is noresca which is uh
they have an amazing paper but
they're they are not open source
they are good for research but it's
non-commercial
and um
and it requires a refere it does not
require as a reference which is super
cool and does not use tech data in
training it also
it is also shown to generalize well to
many tasks and languages and we know
this because it was developed by
facebook that were and they were able to
throw enough computing power on it to
test that out
so uh coming back to our challenge when
we wanted to find the right algorithm
for a comparison we created a version of
this table and just tried out the
the top three
contestants that were seemed for us that
would do the job for our task
and as the field is progressing quickly
in recent years we're always on the
lookout for
new publications this is very much
happening these days and it keeps on
evolving and it's fascinating to follow
this is the last slide and i feel like
this is where i should say some ending
or closing remarks we talked today about
reducing the need to work with humans in
the loop
in our development process without
compromising the outcome and we talked
about cases where humans in the loop are
the ones we need to tag data but also
about cases where we're the humans in
the loop because we constantly need to
listen to that improving and
uh you know
evolving versions of the algorithms that
we're building
i think uh i want to thank you'd agree
with me by now that this is not an easy
task but it is very much an interesting
one
thank you all for being here today i had
fun thinking about and presenting this
talk
are there any questions
any questions
no there's lunch come on um i have like
a really basic question which i haven't
uh i think has been a question even from
the other talk like
um
when you're dealing with audio data
right like you say you're computing
similarity measures between two
waveforms yeah
i can visualize that when i have like
tabular data because i can see the
features and things but how does that
work when you're dealing with how's all
your data represented how do you compute
things with so
many times i would show them visually
like the the the compare i'll do the
comparison on
both
just you know listening to the two
tracks
and also i would do a log male
spectrogram to and sometimes subtract
one logs uh mel from the other to see a
visual representation of what i'm doing
and also i would sometimes
listen to the two tracks in stereo such
that one track will be in one ear and
the other one in the in the other and
then we are very much we're very well
trained to to be able to say whether
we're listening to exactly the same
track or whether there was a bit of a
change it feels like a glitch in the
matrix when it's not exactly the same
you're like wait something is wrong here
and then it helps to to pinpoint where
exactly and whether what what is it that
you know i want to look at okay so is it
fair to say then that there's no like um
perception based in some sense
[Music]
like is there a way to quantify it like
yeah
i mean
what i was showing here is a table that
helps you to to compare the tracks
you're interested
and
and and shift your attention towards
where should you be looking
given the fact that you might be looking
at many different tracks but also in the
end uh you will have to even if you're
doing all of that and you're also you're
already you know
shifting your attention to the places
where there's a big difference between
the tracks you're looking at you in the
end you will still have to listen
yourself to whatever it is you're doing
like there's no way out of this if you
want good results and like everyone is
doing it i don't know anyone who's doing
this without actually listening to a
subportion of what they're doing in the
end it's really important
all right thank you very much um thank
you in the absence of any other
questions i think we can all just go to
lunch
okay
[Applause]
you